wir blicken jetzt in der Debatte auf die
Ukraine allerdings geht es in nicht um
den aktuellen Krieg sondern um Holunder
das beschreibt die Hungersnot in der
Ukraine und da gibt es einen Antrag der
koalitionsfraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP und cdu/csu die möchten
nämlich dass diese Hungersnot nun als
Menschheit zu Verbrechen anerkannt wird
und wir sehen hier auch dass der
aktuelle ukrainische Botschafter olexie
makayef dieser Debatte deswegen von der
Zuschauer Tribüne bei wohnt denn die
Ukraine bemüht sich schon seit 1991 um
eine internationale Anerkennung des
hollodomos als Völkermord das ist
bislang noch umstritten einige Staaten
unter anderem der Vatikan haben sich der
Deutung der Ukraine bereits
angeschlossen Deutschland bisher noch
nicht
aber das soll nun geändert werden so
fordern es eben die Fraktionen Stadien
hatte damals die Zwangskollektivierung
in der Landwirtschaft befohlen und das
führte dazu dass es sehr viel Hunger in
der Ukraine gab
viel Getreide und Saatgut liest Stalin
damals in ukrainischen Dörfern
beschlagnahmen
hier gibt es jetzt Applaus auch für den
ukrainischen Botschafter
es ist in seine große Ehre dass sie
unserer Debatte folgen und auch an den
Mimik ist da der stellvertretende
Außenminister der Ukraine herzlich
willkommen
für die Debatte sind 39 Minuten
Aussprache vorgesehen und als ersten
Redner erteile ich Robin Wagner das Wort
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Robin Wagner eröffnet also die Debatte
erst der europapolitische spreche von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen im Deutschen
Bundestag
frau Präsidentin lieber Herrn
Botschafter
der hungertote eines Menschen verläuft
in den immer gleichen Phasen
in der ersten Phase verbraucht der
Körper seine Glukose Vorräte ein
extremes Hungergefühl setzt ein dazu
ständige Gedanken an Essen
in der zweiten Phase die mehrere Wochen
andauern kann beginnt der Körper sein
Fett zu verbrennen der Organismus wird
dramatisch geschwächt
in der dritten Phase verbraucht der
Körper sein eigenes Eiweiß zerrt Gewebe
und Muskeln auf die Haut wird dünner die
Augen werden größer der Hals wirkt
länger Beine und bauchschwellen an
kleinste Bewegung erfordern große
Kraftanstrengung verschiedenste
Begleiterkrankungen beschleunigen den
Tod
Typhus Diphtherie
dies meine Damen und Herren ist keine
Theorie dies ist das Schicksal von
millionen-ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern
die 1932 1933 am mörderischen Hunger
gestorben sind das sind die Opfer derer
wir heute gedenken
es sind die Schilderungen die uns die
HistorikerInnen überliefern das sind die
Bilder die der aus dem heutigen leviv
stammende polnisch jüdische Jurist
Raphael Lemkin auch vor Augen hatte als
er den Begriff des Genozids des
Völkermords prägte Bilder von Kindern
die im Klassenzimmer sitzen
zusammenbrachen und verstarben
deren Körper anschwollen deren Haut
wegen massivster Unterernährung
durchsichtigt wurde deren hauteriss
Erzählung über Mütter die die Hoffnung
auf das Überleben ihrer Kinder verloren
die Söhne und Töchter präventiv töteten
damit diese den Hunger nicht länger
aushalten mussten
damit sie das wenige Brot nicht teilen
mussten
das ist der Horror der sich hinter dem
Begriff holodumor verbirgt dem Mord
durch Hunger
und dieser Horror hatte seine Ursache
nicht etwa in einer Naturgewalt nicht in
schicksalhaften Missernten auf dem
fruchtbaren Boden der Ukraine dieser
Horror hatte seine Ursache im Kremmel
dort traf der Diktator die grausame
Entscheidung die Kollektivierung mit
Gewalt durchzudrücken und den Hunger zu
verursachen und die Tötung durch Hunger
hatte auch die politische Unterdrückung
des ukrainischen Nationalbewusstseins
der ukrainischen Kultur und Sprache zum
Ziel
meine Damen und Herren die Parallelen
zur heutigen Zeit sind unübersehbar
wieder versucht ein Diktator im Kreml
die Ukraine zu unterwerfen sie zu
vernichten heute nutzt Putin dafür nicht
allein die grausame Gewalt seiner
Söldner und Soldaten er nutzt nicht
allein den Terror von Drohnen und
Raketen er nutzt auch die gezielte
Geschichtsfälschung als
Handlungsgrundlage seines Krieges gegen
die Ukraine
schon in der Sowjetunion wurde der Holo
domor-systematisch verleugnet und
tabuisiert
wir wissen heute dass die russischen
Besatzer das Mahnmal zum Gedenken an den
hungermord in mariopol zerstört haben
für die Verbrechen Stalins gibt es
keinen Platz in der ideologisierten
Geschichtspolitik Wladimir Putins
deswegen verbietet der Organisationen
wie zum Beispiel Memorial
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen gegen
diese Politik des kremmels hilft vor
allem Aufklärung und Bildung die
Schrecken des holodromors genau wie die
deutschen Verbrechen gegen die
Sowjetunion und viele andere Kapitel der
wechselvollen Geschichte der Ukraine und
Osteuropas gehören prominenter in die
Geschichtsbücher und Schulen denn
Wissenschaft nicht nur Empathie
Wissenschaft Widerstandsfähigkeit gegen
Propaganda und Geschichtsklitterung
mit unserem Antrag setzen wir uns mit
der brutalen Wahrheit stalinistischer
Gewalt auseinander nicht um die
deutschen Verbrechen in der Sowjetunion
zu relativieren sondern um aus der
historischen Wahrheit zu lernen
interfraktionell eint uns der Wunsch zu
erinnern zu gedenken zu mahnen und darum
mein Dank an alle Beteiligten in den
Fraktionen die diesen Antrag gemeinsam
getragen haben
und unser Mann muss auch den Blick auf
die Realität in der Ukraine heute
beinhalten am 280 Tag seit Russland vor
den Version wenn wir uns der Wahrheit
nicht verschließen wollen dann dürfen
wir die Augen vor den heutigen Opfern
nicht verschließen zu diesen Opfern
gehört sehr hier wurde heute vor genau
einer Woche getötet durch russische
Raketen
solche wurde gerade von seiner Mutter
gestillt und zum Schlafen in die Wiege
gelegt kurz danach schlugen russische
Raketen in die Entbindungsklinik ein
series Mutter durchlebte neun Monate
einer Schwangerschaft in der Zeit des
Terrors des Krieges
sehr hier wurde vergangene Woche getötet
er wurde 48 Stunden alt
Putins Wunsch bleibt die vollständige
Unterwerfung der Ukraine und ihrer
Menschen russische Staatsziel ist die
Vernichtung der Ukraine als
eigenständiger Staat es macht mich nicht
zum Kriegstreiber belizisten oder
russenhasser wenn ich Kindern wie sehr
hier ein Leben und ein Überleben
ermöglichen möchte wenn ich mich dafür
einsetze dass wir unser starkes
Engagement für die Ukraine noch weiter
stärken
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn
wir es gemeinsam schaffen uns diesem
Vernichtungskrieg entgegenzustellen die
politische historische Einordnung des
solodoments als Völkermord ist darum
nicht nur Mahnungen sondern auch Auftrag
an uns alle das ist unsere Pflicht
diesen Wahnsinn zu stoppen und diesen
Appell richtig nicht nur an uns
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
ich richte ihn an uns alle und damit
auch in die Russinnen und Russen in
Deutschland im Ausland in Russland
stoppen Sie diesen Horror
stoppen Sie diesen Krieg
asternavidia Putina stoppen sie Putina
vielen Dank
fraktionsübergreifend gibt es hier
Applaus für Robin Wagner diese Antrag
wurde ja auch
fraktionsübergreifend eingereicht von
SPD den Grünen FDP und
cdu/csu Fraktion und für die
Unionsfraktion spricht nun Michael
Brandt der Sprecher für Menschenrechte
und humanitäre Hilfe
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Botschafter meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren sie sollten
sterben weil sie Ukrainer sind ein
ganzes Volk sollte sterben so hat es
gestern Abend in Berliner Dom bei einer
besonderen Gedenkveranstaltung der
ukrainische Bischof Bogdan türak
formuliert der Deutsche Bundestag wird
heute anerkennen dass die Ukraine von
der sowjetischen Führung in Moskau zum
Opfer eines Völkermords gemacht wurde
dabei wurden Millionen ermordet und
Hunger wurde zur tödlichen Waffe gemacht
es wurde systematisch selektiert um
Träger der ukrainischen Kultur
Wissenschaft und Geschichte zu verfolgen
zu ermorden ja es sollte das ukrainische
Volk vernichtet werden nichts weniger
spricht Bände historisch und politisch
dass der Massenmörder Stalin dessen
Denkmäler unter Gorbatschow und Jelzin
weniger wurden und verschwanden von
Vladimir Putin wieder zu einer Ikone
Russlands gemacht wurde es war kein
Zufall dass bei der Besetzung mariopols
durch die Truppen Putins das Denkmal für
die Opfer des holodumor gezielt und
propagandistisch vernichtet worden ist
wenn sich manche heute fragen warum wir
von der Brutalität und dem
Vernichtungswillen eines Putin
überrascht worden dann müssen sie sich
auch fragen warum sie die Zeichen an der
Wand nicht gesehen haben warum die
Restauration eines der größten
menschheitsverbrechers durch Putin sie
nicht viel früher aufgeschreckt hat und
für uns alle muss heute gelten was Lehre
der eigenen deutschen Geschichte ist nie
wieder darf weder in deutschen noch im
russischen Namen geschehen was durch den
holoumor und die Nazis an Massenmord in
der Ukraine begangen wurde
einer der renommiertesten Kenner der
Geschichte der Ukraine Timothy Snyder
hat darauf hingewiesen dass die
schlimmste Phase des Holocausts mit den
deutschen Massenmorden in der Ukraine
begann er hat auch darauf hingewiesen
dass in der gesamten Sowjetunion die
Ukraine und nicht Russland die
prozentual und auch nominal mit Abstand
höchste Zahl an Opfern durch den
deutschen Vernichtungskrieg zu beklagen
hat noch immer und das wollen wir heute
ein Stück verändern wird ausgerechnet in
Deutschland dieses enorme Leiden der
Ukrainer sowohl unter Stalin als dann
unter Nazi Deutschland nicht hinreichend
erinnert nicht genügend respektiert und
nicht in der deutschen Haltung gegenüber
der Ukraine berücksichtigt das liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen muss sich
ändern und zwar gründlich
so kommen wir heute dazu zwar später als
andere endlich den Völkermord an den
Ukrainern durch Moskau als einen solchen
auch anzuerkennen gerade wird deutschen
stehen hier in einer besonderen
historischen Schuld und Verantwortung
gegenüber gegenüber der Ukraine und es
war nicht richtig dass unsere
Initiativen im Parlament schon früher
vor dem 90 Jahr des Tag auch mit Verweis
auf Russland nie mitgetragen wurden
es ist schlicht nicht fair gegenüber den
Opfern dieses Völkermords und ich sage
auch das ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
auch die erste Reihe des Bundeskabinetts
heute an dieser Debatte teilnimmt kein
einziger Bundesminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir verneigen
uns vor den Opfern für uns heißt nie
wieder heute wir dürfen nicht noch
einmal schuldig werden wenn wir der
Ukraine nicht endlich mit allem helfen
was wir tun können werden wir ein
zweites Mal schuldig Slava Ukraine
Michael Brandt ist natürlich auch wenn
das hier ein fraktionsübergreifender
Antrag ist weiterhin in der Opposition
und hat dementsprechend auch hier noch
mal die Bundesregierung kritisiert dass
hier kein Bundesminister der Debatte
beiwohnt Gabriela Heinrich spricht jetzt
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrter Herr Botschafter sehr
geehrter Herr stellvertretende
Außenminister liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es gibt Debatten bei denen Parteipolitik
und Abgrenzung voneinander schlichtweg
unangemessen sind und es gibt Anträge
die erst dann Gewicht entfalten wenn
eine breite Mehrheit des politischen
Spektrums dahinter steht ich bin deshalb
froh dass wir zum holidumor heute
gemeinsam agieren danke dafür vielen
herzlichen Dank
Dankeschön auch gerade deswegen weil wir
aus Deutschland eigener Vergangenheit
eine besondere Verantwortung ableiten
innerhalb der internationalen
Gemeinschaft Menschenrechtsverbrechen
kenntlich zu machen und aufzuarbeiten
auch wenn es bei meinen Vorrednerinnen
auch schon Anklang ich glaube wir
sollten uns die Fakten noch mal vor
Augen führen die nackten Zahlen schon am
Ende der 1920er Jahre waren Lebensmittel
in der Sowjetunion knapp
hunderttausende verhungerten im Winter
1931 32 am 14 dezember 1932 unterschrieb
Stalin den Beschluss über die
getreidebeschaffung in der Ukraine im
Nordkaukasus und in der westregion
im darauffolgenden Winter verhungerten
in der Ukraine drei bis 3,5 Millionen
Menschen und das ist nur eine Schätzung
auch in Kasachstan waren es zwei
Millionen Menschen weitere
hunderttausende verhungerten in der
kubanregion und entlang der Flüsse Wolga
und Don
wie gesagt diese Zahlen sind Schätzungen
aber jede dieser Zahlen schildert das
Ausmaß der unvorstellbaren Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit hinter all
diesen Millionen stehen Menschen die
qualvoll an Unterernährung starben die
wenigen zeitgenössischen Berichte
beschreiben grausame Szenen verhungern
der Kinder mit aufgeblähten Bäuchen und
irgendwas noch mal deutlich zu machen es
waren geplant ungeheure Verbrechen
diese Katastrophe beruht nicht auf
missern die Ernte im gesamten Land wurde
kollektiviert und der Bevölkerung das
Essen einfach weggenommen
der Hunger wurde als Waffe und als
mittelstalinistischer Säuberungen
eingesetzt der Zentralstaat zielte damit
auch auf die Unterdrückung des
ukrainischen Nationalbewusstsein
Angehörige der ukrainischen Eliten
wurden verfolgt sie wurden inhaftiert
und sie wurden ermordet wenn sie nicht
schon verhungert waren
von all dem betroffen war die gesamte
Ukraine nicht nur die Region die als
Kornkammer gelten
sehr verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Historiker Gerhard Simon bezeichnete
das Verschweigen als den letzten Akt
dieser Verbrechen ein halbes Jahrhundert
lang sei der Holo Dumont zum Tabu zum
nicht geschehen geworden nicht einmal in
geheimen Dokumenten der sowjetischen
Führung sind die Hunger Toten erwähnt
nur in den Familien und unter Freunden
sei das Wissen um das Grauen dieser
Jahre erhalten geblieben so Simon aus
politisches historischer Sicht heute ein
Völkermord
erst seit 1998 gibt es in der Ukraine
den offiziellen Tag der Erinnerung an
die Opfer des solodomorr immer am 4
Samstag im November und dieser Tag ist
bedeutend
Traumata die nicht aufgearbeitet werden
belasten nicht nur die Überlebenden und
die Zeitzeugen mit all den Folgen die
wir heute aus der Traumaforschung kennen
vererben sie sich auch an die nächsten
Generationen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der hohle
domorr war eine gewollte und geplante
Hungersnot um die Ukraine gefügig zu
machen um sie dem sowjetischen System
einzufahren die Ukraine hat das nicht
vergessen und doch wir werden es nicht
vergessen was passiert also jetzt
was passiert also jetzt wenn ein
Vladimir Putin sagt die Ukraine seien
unveräußerlicher Teil der russischen
Geschichte Kultur und Religion was
passiert jetzt bei der sinnlosen
Zerstörung der Infrastruktur was
passiert angesichts der vielen Opfer der
vielen Toten und Verwundeten was
passiert angesichts eines Krieges der
darauf angelegt ist die Ukraine zu
vernichten wieder zu vernichten
womit Putin nicht gerechnet hat
dass auch die Erinnerung an den
hulodomore die Ukrainerin und Ukrainer
zusammenschweißt der holotumor hat sich
tief im nationalen Gedächtnis der
Ukraine eingegraben und dass wir heute
gemeinsam diesen Antrag verabschieden
das herrschweist uns vielleicht auch
noch einmal mehr mit der Ukraine
zusammen das Unrecht von damals muss
halt solches benannt und aufgearbeitet
werden und das heißt für unsere Politik
heute lassen Sie uns die Ukraine wie zum
Antrag steht als Opfer der
imperialistischen Politik Wladimir
Putins weiterhin politisch finanziell
humanitär und militärisch unterstützen
vielen Dank
die
stellvertretendefektionsvorsitzende der
SPD-Fraktion Gabriela heinrich war das
und für die afd-fraktion spricht nun
Mark Jungen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der holodomore Ukrainisch für Massenmord
durch Hunger ist eines der großen
Menschheitsverbrechen des 20
Jahrhunderts Lenin hat es 1922 bereits
angekündigt wir werden noch den Terror
einschließlich des wirtschaftlichen
Terrors verwenden den exekutierte dann
Stalin in unfassbarer Brutalität die
zwangskollektivierten Kulaken also die
den Kommunisten verhassten
selbstständigen Bauern wurden 19323 in
der ganzen Sowjetunion zu unerfüllbar
hohen Abgaben verpflichtet wer sich
nicht fügte dem Namen bewaffnete
Kommandos die gesamte Ernte und
sämtliche Lebensmittelvorräte Weg die
Ukraine ausgerechnet die Kornkammer
Europas traf es besonders hart auch weil
Stalin das dortige Nationalbewusstsein
eliminieren wollte
das Land wurde abgeriegelt Bahnfahrten
war nicht mehr erlaubt bis zu vier
Millionen Menschen wurden dem sicheren
Hungertod ausgeliefert wenn wir heute an
dieses monströse Verbrechen erinnern
dann muss die Lehre doch vor allem eines
sein die sozialistische Ideologie mit
ihrem Hass auf Individualität und
Freiheit mit ihrem gleichmachungsterror
und ihrem waren einen neuen Menschen
schaffen zu können ist abzulehnen und zu
bekämpfen wo immer sie in neuer
Verkleidung ihr scheußliches Haupt
erhebt das gilt für die
nationalsozialistische Variante aber es
gilt eben auch für die internationale
Variante die sich hinter sowohl
klingenden Parolen wie Gerechtigkeit
oder Fortschritt versteckt die
afd-fraktion hat bereits vor drei Jahren
über den Holodomor hier im Deutschen
Bundestag informiert damals hat es kaum
jemanden interessiert bei Verbrechen im
kommunistischen Machtbereich hat unser
lebenslastiges politisches
Systemmanagement jahrzehntelang lieber
weggeschaut
man kommt ja auch bei dem Gedenken an
die SED-Verbrechen nicht recht voran das
Mahnmal ist noch immer nicht gebaut da
engagierte Leiter der Gedenkstätte
Hohenschönhausen wurde elegant
abserviert und so weiter warum ist den
gleichen politischen Kräften die
Erinnerung an den Holunder jetzt
plötzlich so wichtig wir fürchten aus
schiefen Gründen in ihren Reden hier und
ja auch in den sonstigen Verlautbarungen
findet eine starke Parallelisierung und
teils ja schon fast eine in Einsetzung
der historischen Ereignisse mit dem
heutigen Krieg Russland gegen die
Ukraine statt die Heidelberger
Historikerin Tanja pentner spricht dem
Spiegel sehr zurecht von einer
unglücklichen Verpflichtung separater
historischer Kontexte in ihrem Antrag
und die genozidforscherin Christin Platz
warnt im Deutschlandradio Kultur mit dem
Begriff des Genozids oder Völkermords
muss man sehr vorsichtig umgehen denn
gerade im Krieg mit der häufig
strategisch und auch propagandistisch
eingesetzt Zitat Ende
Intelligenz hat auch Wladimir Putin die
Ukraine des Völkermords an den Russen in
den Ostprovinzen bezichtigt wir sollten
die Maßlosigkeit solcher Vorwürfe hier
im Westen nicht spiegeln meine Damen und
Herren
aber die deutsche Politik berauscht sich
wie üblich am Hochgefühl ihrer
moralischen Überlegenheit
Außenministerin bärburg spricht mit
Blick auf Russlands Kriegsführung die
bisher laut unstatistik rund 6.500
zivile Opfer gefordert hat jetzt sogar
von einem
Zivilisationsbruch ein Ausdruck der
sonst dem Holocaust vorbehalten ist Frau
beerburg wo immer sie heute sind eine
weiße Staatsführung zeigt sich gerade in
einer Krise nicht in maximaler
rhetorischer Eskalation sondern in Maß
und Umsicht mit Blick auf den Frieden
den sie im Auge behalten sollten beides
lassen sie eklatant vermissen und noch
einen Irrtum von ihnen möchte ich hier
zum Abschluss korrigieren die Ukrainer
die jetzt mit der Waffe in der Hand und
vielleicht mit der Erinnerung an den
holodorant im Herzen ihre Heimat
verteidigen sie tun es nicht für die
Werte des internationalen Regenbogens
für diversity Toleranz und
Gleichstellung sie tun es für die
Souveränität ihr Landes für den Erhalt
ihres Volkes und ihrer Kultur darin
haben Sie unsere Solidarität an den
hollodomorr ist auch zu erinnern aber
die Instrumentalisierung der Geschichte
die sie betreiben lehnen wir vielen Dank
war das für die
afd-fraktion im Anschluss an diese
Debatte werden die Abgeordneten direkt
dann auch über diesen Antrag abstimmen
Ulrich Lechte spricht man als nächstes
erst ob man im Auswärtigen Ausschuss für
die Liberalen in deutschen Parlament
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Exzellenzen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die manitan
aber in Vagina und Knut Abraham meinen
Dank für den exzellenten Antrag wir
wollen im Deutschen Bundestag heute
erinnern mahnen und gedenken dem
grausamen Verbrechen des holomers damit
geben wir eine der größten humanitären
Katastrophen des 20 Jahrhunderts die
Öffentlichkeit die sie verdient
Stadions geplanter und begangener
Massenmord in der Ukraine ist ein
Menschheitsverbrechen das bis in die
späten 80er Jahre von Russland
bestritten und vor der Weltgemeinschaft
verborgen wurde
ausgerechnet heute wird es dort erneut
geleugnet
über 3 Millionen Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer sind im holodumor in den Jahren
1932 und 33 zum Opfer gefallen davon
betroffen war nicht nur Bauern aus den
Getreide produzierenden Regionen sondern
jede Familien der gesamten Ukraine war
davon betroffen es war eine
unvorstellbare Strafe für den Widerstand
der Ukraine gegen die sowjetische
Zwangskollektivierung und für ihre
Ablehnung der sowjetischen Herrschaft
mit der Vernichtung der ukrainischen
Kultur Sprache und Traditionen sollte
der Völkermord letztlich vollzogen
werden
gemäß der Definition handelt es sich bei
einem Völkermord um einen gezielten
Versuch eine Nation zumindest teilweise
zu eliminieren im Falle des holodomore
ergibt sich die Tötungsabsicht eindeutig
aus der Beschlagnahmung von
Nahrungsmitteln und der bewussten
Blockade der hungergebiete Menschen
wurden erschossen weil sie Lebensmittel
besaßen
insofern möchten wir hier und heute die
Gelegenheit nutzen und nochmals klar
betonen aus historisch politischer
Perspektive handelte sich beim
hollytumor um Völkermord
es war
ein menschenverachtendes Verbrechen das
von Stalin und seinen Schergen politisch
gewollt künstlich herbeigeführt und
systematisch durchgeführt wurde die
Beschäftigung mit der Vergangenheit
macht einen fassungslos und lässt Tränen
fließen und erneut ist die Ukraine Ziel
unglaublicher Verbrechen denn werden
1932 respektive 33 nur wenig nach außen
drang sind wir als Weltöffentlichkeit
gegenwärtig Zeuge der russischen
Kriegsverbrechen und das erneuten teros
gegen die ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung
die aktuelle Kriegsführung Russlands
zeigt gewisse Parallelen der
Vergangenheit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen denn erneut wird Hunger auch
als Waffe eingesetzt wie Sie sicherlich
erinnern wurde zu Beginn des russischen
angriffskriegs vielfach Getreide aus der
Ukraine gestohlen
es wurden gezielt Versorgungsketten
unterbrochen und fluchtkorridore für die
Zivilbevölkerung bombardiert
mittlerweile nutzt Putin vermehrt Kälte
und Dunkelheit als Kriegsmittel um
unseren europäischen Partnern die
Ukraine pausenlos unter Druck zu setzen
und in den russisch besetzten Gebieten
wir mit erneut auch Hunger als Mittel
gegen die dortige Bevölkerung eingesetzt
all dies um die russische mehr von der
Entnazifizierung der Ukraine aufrecht zu
erhalten die ukrainische Bevölkerung zu
brechen und ihnen ihre staatliche
Souveränität zu nehmen doch damit meine
Damen und Herren ist schon Stalin von 90
Jahren gescheitert und für mich steht
zweifelsfrei fest dass auch Putin
Schalter wird
die Ukraine
die Ukraine wird diesen Krieg nicht
verlieren die Ukraine wird als Nation
Fortbestehen als unabhängiger
demokratischer Staat das ist nicht
verhandelbar dabei werden wir Sie auch
weiterhin mit allen Möglichkeiten
unterstützen das habe ich den
ukrainischen Botschafter in einem
persönlichen Gespräch versichert mit dem
von uns eingebrachten Antrag wird der
Völkermord in das damit verbundenen
massenhafte ukrainische leit anerkannt
gleichzeitig wollen wir mit dem Antrag
zum historischen Verständnis beitragen
und den russischen
Geschichtsrevisionismus im Keim
ersticken vor dem Hintergrund des
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen Bomben
Terrors gegen unschuldige Zivilisten und
zivile Infrastruktur ist jetzt die Zeit
Farbe zu bekennen für die Ukraine die
auch für unser aller Freiheit kämpft
Putins ansehen die Ukraine von der
Landkarte zu tilgen wird scheitern sein
Angriff gegen die Freiheit und
Demokratie unseres Westens wird
definitiv scheitern Putin muss scheitern
wir die Parteien der Mitte im Deutschen
Bundestag stehen an der Seite der
Ukraine die unfassbaren Verbrechen gegen
die Menschlichkeit des 20 Jahrhunderts
dürfen sich im 21 Jahrhundert nicht
wiederholen gerade wir Deutschen stehen
hier wie kein anderes Volk auf dieser
Welt in der Pflicht
Ulrich Lechte war das für die
FDP-Fraktion Gregor Gysi ist nun als
nächstes auf der Rednerliste erst der
Sprecher für Außenpolitik der
Linksfraktion hier im Deutschen
Bundestag
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Minister Herr Botschafter
Lehnin hat Max völlig falsch an einer
Stelle korrigiert max war der Auffassung
dass der Kapitalismus für die
Industrialisierung zuständig ist man in
erst sozialistischen Versuch nur in dem
entwickelsten kapitalistischen Land
unternehmen können Leni meint aber es
ginge auch in Russland völlig
unterentwickelt diesbezüglich und Stalin
griff dann zum zur terroristischen
Industrialisierung und
Zwangskollektivierung und brachte
Millionen Menschen durch Hunger ums
Leben ein schlimmes Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit es ist gut daran zu
erinnern
aber was stört mich am Antrag sie gehen
davon aus dass es ein Genozid ein
Völkermord war sich also dieser Wert
zwischen Führung aus rassistischen und
ethnischen Motiven gegen die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer stellte und
sie aushungerte in Wirklichkeit stellt
sie sich Stalin aus politischen Gründen
gegen alle die die terroristische
Industrialisierung und
Zwangskollektivierung ablehnten
unabhängig von ihrer Nationalität und
oder Ethnie in vielen Millionen Menschen
in der Ukraine dem Nordkaukasus der
wolga-region dem süduralgebiet
Westsibirien und Kasachstan zum Opfer
der Petitionsausschuss des Bundestages
stellte 2017 zum hollow more Fest eine
abschließende Bewertung ob sie als Opfer
eines Notiz im Sinne der späteren
völkermordkonvention der Vereinten
Nationen zu verstehen sind steht noch
aus dennoch spricht einiges dagegen auch
der Europarat verurteilte das
menschlichkeitsverbrechen lehnte aber
die Bezeichnung als genuizid ab wenn man
den Antrag liest hat man auch den
Eindruck der Gleichstellung von Hitler
und Stalin stalin war schlimm sehr
schlimm aber kein Hitler wir dürfen nie
vergessen Hitler und nicht stalin hat
den Zweiten Weltkrieg geführt vor allem
aber hat Hitler die industrielle
Vernichtung von Millionen Menschen zum
Beispiel ein Auschwitz zu verantworten
ohne das sind überhaupt interessierte ob
diese Menschen für oder gegen ihn sein
sechs Millionen Jüdinnen und Juden
wurden nur wegen ihres Judentums
ermordet
alle in Deutschland müssen die Suche
nach einem zweiten Hitler und einem
zweiten Auschwitz aufgeben beides gab es
nur einmal Joscha Fischer sprach 1999 im
Bezug auf das kasso Kosovo davon er
wolle kein zweites Auschwitz heute hält
die Außenministerin bärburg Russland ein
Zivilisationsbruch vor ein Begriff der
bisher ausschließlich für die Schuhe
angewandt wurde beides mehr als
bedenklich ferner die Sowjetunion hat
einen entscheidenden Beitrag zur
Zerschlagung des Hitler Faschismus
geleistet das darf man nie vergessen
beim Hitler stalinpark vergessen sie zu
erwähnen dass die sowjetische Führung
vorher versuchte ein Zusammengehen mit
Großbritannien und Frankreich zu
erreichen was insbesondere
Großbritannien ablehnte deshalb wandte
sich darin einen Hitler um mit dem zu
erwartenden Krieg möglichst wenig zu tun
zu haben was aber nur vorübergehen
gelangen
sie wollen weiter die Ukraine
militärische unterstützen ich teile
nicht die Auffassung der Regierung dass
die Ukraine Russland besiegen kann in
Übereinstimmung mit der
US-amerikanischen Militärführung glaube
ich dass weder der Kollege noch Russland
in diesem Krieg ich bin gleich fertig
noch Russland in diesem Krieg siegen
können und deshalb bin ich für ein sehr
schnellen Waffenstillstand
darf ein kriegen nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg und der Verantwortung für den
schlimmsten Krieg der
Menschheitsgeschichte nie Kollege macht
es aber ich sag nur noch den letzten
Satz Frau Präsident wir Herr Kollege
Teil das Verbrechen deshalb können wir
nicht gegen den Eintrag Stimmen Herr
Kollege wir haben auch Kritik deshalb
können wir nicht für Herr Kollege reden
hat das Wort für die SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen Exzellenzen
der holodomore ist in der Geschichte des
ukrainischen Volkes ein zentraler
Erinnerungsort ein Tiefpunkt seiner
leidvollen Geschichte
nehmen wir den heutigen Tag zum Anlass
anders als der Redner der afd-fraktion
in erster Linie der Millionen
unschuldiger Opfer des holodomos zu
gedenken und an ihr Schicksal zu
erinnern
vor ihnen den Opfern wollen wir uns
heute verneigen
und Ihnen versichern dass wir sie
niemals vergessen werden es darf auch
kein Vergessen geben denn der Holo domor
ist ein unauslöschbarer Teil der
europäischen Geschichte auch wenn es
politische Kräfte gibt die das negieren
wollen
vor allen Dingen ist der aber auch die
Geschichte menschenverachtender
Totalitarismen
die Gefahren und Verbrechen dieser
totalismus stärken
[Musik]
im
kollektiven Bewusstsein
vieler Gesellschaften
einen falschen Umgang mit der Geschichte
wir müssen dafür kämpfen dass wir mit
einem offenen und transparenten Umgang
der Geschichte die offenen
Gesellschaften stärken damit sie
widerstehen gegenüber denen die
Geschichte verbiegen und verleugnen
wollen
deshalb ist es völlig richtig und
überfällig dass das Parlament heute den
Holodomor aus politisches historischer
Sicht als Völkermord einordnet das ist
die gemeinsame Aufgabe aller
DemokratInnen und Demokraten denn diese
Klarheit ist wichtig um
Geschichtsfälschung und
Geschichtsrevisionismus entgegenzutreten
an dieser
Stelle möchte ich den dank den Uli
Lechte an die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verteilt hat auch gerne zurückgeben es
war gut dass wir über Fraktionsgrenzen
hinweg sehr vertrauensvoll an diesem
Antrag zusammengearbeitet haben und sehr
geehrter Herr Botschafter makeef auch
ihnen möchte ich ganz herzlich danken
ich danke Ihnen dafür dass Sie mit uns
Abgeordneten in vertraulichen und
persönlichen Gesprächen sehr offen und
konstruktiv sich ausgetauscht haben und
nicht über Twitter
die heutige Debatte
und der darauf folgende Beschluss zum
Holodomor sind nicht nur wichtig um als
Parlament die Opfer dieses Verbrechens
zu Ehren sie sind auch dringend geboten
weil wir erleben dass in Europa
Geschichte leider immer noch als
Instrument oder gar Waffe eingesetzt
wird die Versuche einen
multi-perspektivischen Blick auf die
Geschichte durch Renationalisierung
einzudampfen die finden wir nicht nur im
Kreml sondern auch bei
rechtspopulistischen Regierungen in der
Europäischen Union den müssen wir uns
entschieden entgegenstellen
der holode more sollte uns allen eine
Mahnung sein gerade aber auch im Umgang
mit totalitären Staaten
seinen verbrecherlichen Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine hat Wladimir Putin
nicht nur militärisch vorbereitet die
Fälschung der geschichtlichen Tatsachen
inklusive der versuchten Rehabilitierung
des Massenmörders Stalin die
geschichtliche Herleitung für eine
Legierung der Existenz der ukrainischen
Nation das waren keine Zufälle
Geschichtsrevisionismus gehört zum Kampf
der totalitären gegen offene
Gesellschaften und dagegen müssen wir
alle Vorgehen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
unser holodomor-antrag hat aber auch
angesichts der gezielten Tötung
ukrainischer Zivilistin und Zivilisten
im jetzigen Krieg durch Russland die
Bombardierung ziviler ukrainischer
Infrastruktur um das Land zu
terrorisieren um die Menschen frieren
erfrieren zu lassen
der Verschleppung von hunderttausenden
von Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern und der
bewussten russischen in kaufname das
ukrainisches Getreide nicht in die
ärmsten Länder der Welt exportiert
werden kann einen erschreckenden Bezug
zur Gegenwart und den sollte niemand
relativieren oder leugnen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deshalb sage ich jeder Schritt der zur
Aufklärung von Menschheitsverbrechen
beiträgt ist ein wichtiger Schritt den
es zu unterstützen gilt mit diesem
Antrag können wir dazu beitragen dass
die Erinnerung an den Holodomor
aufrechterhalten und weiter verbreitet
wird denn Versöhnung und Frieden kann es
nur auf der Grundlage geschichtlicher
Wahrheiten geben vielen Dank
[Applaus]
guten
Knut Abraham sitzt im Ausschuss für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
herr Gysi ich weiß wirklich nicht
welchen Antrag Sie gelesen haben ganz
sicherlich nicht unseren in diesem in
diesem Antrag gibt es kein Wort der
Gleichsetzung der Verbrechen von Hitler
und Stalin das steht da nicht drin
sondern sie haben hier den Vergleich
eingeführt in diese Debatte sie haben
den Vergleich eingeführt und zwar aus
einem sehr bösen Grund um nämlich die
Schuld der sowjetischen Führung zu
relativieren zu relativieren und andere
Dinge die später in der Geschichte
geschehen sind hier eingeführt haben
nein das ist wirklich ein akzeptabel und
das hat mit unserem Antrag und dem
gemeinsamen Anliegen und so habe ich das
in ganzen Parlament verstanden auch in
dieser Debatte bisher wirklich keinen
guten Dienst erwiesen
in der Ukraine gibt es keine Familie die
nicht vom Holodomor betroffen war
Millionen Menschen verhungerten Benehmen
weniger Monate wir haben das gehört und
wir wissen warum
dass wir heute hier im Plenum des
Deutschen Bundestages diesen
interfraktionellen Antrag beraten und
beschließen indem die Einordnung des
holomer als Völkermord eingeordnet wird
also geschieht erfüllt mich mit
Erleichterung und Dankbarkeit
Erleichterung weil wir endlich diesen
Weg gegangen sind und Dankbarkeit das
ist schon angekommen angeklungen an die
Kurve Berichterstatter Robin Wagner
Ulrich schlechte und die manitan das war
eine ebenso
verantwortungsvolle wie vertrauensvolle
Zusammenarbeit die unsere Beratung
ausgemacht hat unser gemeinsamer Antrag
hat fünf Anliegen zum einen Trauer
Respekt und ehrendes Andenken an die und
vier Millionen Opfer
zum anderen auch die klare Benennung der
Täter es ist übrigens höchste Zeit dass
diese Verantwortlichkeiten auch in
Russland aufgearbeitet werden
zum dritten geht es in unserem Antrag
darum dass Wissen über den Holodomor in
Deutschland zu verbreitern ja darüber
hinaus die Kenntnis der Geschichte des
östlichen Teils unseres Kontinents zu
verbessern das Ausmaß dieses Verbrechens
steht nämlich in einem starken Gegensatz
zu dessen geringer Bekanntheit im Westen
Europas
sich in diesem historischen Moment
dieser europäischen Geschichte nicht
bewusst zu sein hat dramatische Folgen
es ist die Unwissenheit über den
holodromor und Stalins Verbrechen in der
Ukraine und das jahrzehntelange
verdrängen die zu den Fehleinschätzungen
zu Putin und zu und seiner
revisionistischen Geschichtspolitik
geführt haben ist diese Fehleinschätzung
beruhen auf den Unwissen über die
Geschichte des Vollautomat und der
gesamten Region
mit dem Antrag wollen wir viertens klar
machen dass die Ukraine im Gegensatz zu
damals heute nicht alleine steht die
Ukraine ist Teil der europäischen
Familie der hollodome war daher auch ein
Verbrechen an unseren ukrainischen
Familienmitgliedern das uns alle angeht
uns alle betrifft aber der wichtigste
Aspekt ist natürlich die Gegenwart denn
wir sehen heute
denselben Willen zum Völkermord heute
durch Kälte und erfrieren warum schießen
die Russen Raketen in die zivile Wärme
und Stromversorgung nicht um Krieg zu
führen sondern um Terror gegen die
zivilver Bevölkerung zu verüben warum
weil sie Ukrainer sind weil sie nicht
bereit sind ihre Identität ihre
Identität und ihren Staat aufzugeben und
weil Putin wie einst Stalin versucht das
ukrainische national Bewusstsein zu
brechen meine Damen und Herren ich
vermeiden nicht ich vermeide mich vor
den Opfern des hollodome und bitte sie
alle sehr herzlich unserem Antrag ihre
Zustimmung zu geben vielen Dank
abraham war das hier in der DEB
atte zu des holodemores als
Völker Mord wir verlassen für heute den
Deutschen Bundestag morgen sind wir
natürlich ab 8:45 Uhr wieder live für
Sie da aus dem Deutschen Bundestag da
wird es unter anderem um die Gas und
strompreisbremse gehen Julia Verlinden
von den Grünen und Andreas Jung von der
CDU
CSU-Fraktion werden da im Interview sein
hier bei Phoenix geht es nun weiter mit
der Tag und Thomas Bade